but hang on a second is there is there a
trick
he has grabbed this pawn um has he made
a mistake ivanka
oh yeah yeah no i'm just looking at is
there some
there's a fork black can now capture
this knight
with his queen he can give up his queen
temporarily giving check and once the
king takes he can drop back with his
knight with a double attack we've
highlighted so many of these forks these
double attacks black would actually win
a piece here but the game is still
balanced white has so many
pawns in return so black will end up
with an extra bishop but white has two
pawns
um this one it might be maxim bachelor's
best chance we've got we've got to see
the expression on the players faces when
uh
because i'm pretty sure
[Laughter]
you all know and uh maximum verse
telegraph
relaxed he knows what's coming and he's
done it
we've gone for it the queens have left
the board look at the white king the
white king
marching forward now um white is a piece
down remember white has a bishop less
but that white king is so active and
white has two pawns extra
so this one is still roughly in the
balance it's still very very tense